I'm just I'm just recording this
vertically just because I know what I'm
about to say and I just want document
like it's so obvious to me what's gonna
happen a levy in snapchat like our
execution these next 12 months it's
gonna be it's gonna be so [ __ ] crazy
what it all looks like a year from today
like maybe you'll use this video to show
the numbers as a matter of fact make
sure you document my YouTube subscribers
and my snails say right now a snapchat
story how many stories that mobile use
I'm getting and will literally run this
video put in your calendar right now a
year from today we will put put this out
because what a lot of people understand
is its execution and we've put the
pieces in place a full execution right
yep
oh and there's one other thing pure
talent and ud rocker talented but I I
knew that I really talented
dailyvee 0:03 I'm rapping and this up
would be so all about the snapchat
I just pay attention
you really do well thank you
yeah it's going great and it keeps we
need to like website traffic email
interaction coaching applications yet
oh we need a works
Oh
snapchat
I'm in as of today just like just like
the big business yeah I'm into snapshot
I've been doing August so you know any
lightly I'm gonna hire my own
videographers no no I'm gonna do it I
agree I'm going hard at stuff somebody
might get a d-roc blush one thing I
learned from having a relationship with
Laz is as I'm getting older I want to do
business with people that I like I think
in your 20s and 30s you're trying to
make it happen I think when you start
getting into a different place in your
career to me he's one of the best dudes
like anything I he would ever want to do
I'd want to be involved in and so I just
think uh getting to that place where
you're just doing business with people
you actually genuinely like is the Holy
Grail Oh morning how are you
cause what I Airport uh
fifteen minutes yet 20 minutes I need
two cars here you try hitting something
tight yes yes okay
Heera yep get in here I mean we got to
show people that I shower and I think I
smell be rocked this is what happens
when when I pack and Lizzie doesn't pack
because you've got everything and imma
give it got it all except socks well
yeah that's Gary Vaynerchuk how are you
super well the thing that I'm most
fascinated in watching is that people
are blown away that there's no natural
discovery within a snapchat world you
have to use other channels to really get
your exposure and so taking a step back
in 2016 if you're one of the biggest
brands in the world thinking about how
you're going to use your website your
email your packaging your facebook your
Instagram your advertising in other
places to drive a a following on
snapchat using snapchat influencers
other things that nature and then having
a creative strategy within it for your
stories that's the number one thing
people should be doing but but what what
I think you know that I also know is
there is not a single company that is
ready to allocate hundreds of thousands
of dollars in creative just against a
snapchat story five days a week seven
days a week 365 days a year
full throttle you know 500 thousand 1
million dollars two million dollars in
production fee to be the best brand on
snapchat by putting out a compelling
story which which consists of seven
videos and three pictures every 24 hours
of the day yeah I totally agree with
that statement now how do you feel cuz
I've seen a lot of friends try and
really try get you to their their site
sitter snapchat help but how do you kind
of how do you feel that people can
actually make that happen like how do
you think that you know it's not just be
looking at your user name and going out
maybe like how can you actually get
your name you know I think I think
that's a tremendous question I think
every brand has to have its own kind of
content strategy I think a lot of brands
are going to go for the lowest common
denominator which is they're going to
run contests or follow us on you know on
snapchat and blah blah blah will happen
and you can win a free trip or free this
or that what I think the right thing to
do is make an incredible story and then
download a piece of it right and then
upload it on your other channels so that
when people see it in a tweet or in a
Facebook post or an Instagram 15 second
clip they get so excited about what what
else is there it compels them to go
follow it the content is always king you
know we say the marketing all the time
it's super cliche the problem is most
people don't execute on it and so
instead of doing a cheap move just to
get as many views on your story as
possible by giving stuff away or
incentivizing it I say make great
quality content use your other social
vehicles and other digital and even
traditional vehicles to share that
content and then compel people to come
and watch I completely agree like the
like the boil things like that I really
like the way that that happened I know
that you guys yeah we weren't that yeah
and that's and that's how we think about
things we're religious the one thing
about vaynermedia when I started it six
years ago is we are religious about
storytelling properly on the platform so
what we put on Facebook isn't going to
be what we put on snapchat blah blah
blah what but when we're trying to build
something up we don't mind using some of
the other channels as distribution for
like my example for snapchat to build
that base and then we go back to going
native and really driving success that's
a great strategy definitely gives me a
lot to work with
I think they can definitely make a
really great article from Alton thank
you so much for all your insight of
course hope you have a great great 2016
talk to you soon well the big idea you
know dj khaled has uh um yeah whoo
booming and booming
why you say yeah but everything yep just
want to give a huge shout out my daily
reading nicholas megalis one of the most
talented I don't know if you can get in
here you rocket in here because he just
got me super pumped he gave me a shout
out on his snap one of the great bynars
and one of the great talents i know and
just way more importantly one of the one
of the best dudes you'll ever meet so
google nicholas or actually bureau we
can edit here m EG al is megalis real
talent real talent just a great dude
thanks necklace i hope you like all the
episode like where's my job ah hi Misha
and Xander it's daddy
I love you guys I miss you and thank you
so much for your videos have the best
day I'll talk to you soon mommy will
face time with us later I love you long
before it was cool I myself was an
entrepreneur getting decent apps in
everyone's face see your face dear I
should pop this off alpha self alphas
legit what you know what I might bring
that back unlike you know the people
what SS that fires me up big thank you
so much and then what's this
may see a new job such a pleasure
so I'm thinking oh I do a damn blob
don't wear any sort of No
it's here
awesome yeah it's upstairs amazing
how's fun so he's fun when uh when you
think you got to go travel it's the same
building I'm just gonna catch up with me
no yep
yes
Oh
hey Gary how are you I'm well everyone's
eating so I can I can literally I'm
great I can lick setup and thank you
a lot of you asked me how I keep my
phone charged ghetto style thank you how
are you you're welcome
see I'm it yellow pretty good so whether
you're in fitness or in social media or
in insurance people going to want to
talk about what only so much time so
whether you're in insurance
social media sports fishing people going
to want to know what it means to your
industry now that snapchat is on and if
you're watching this it means that
you're starting to pay attention to
what's going on on snapchat you want to
hear my thoughts on it you're getting
curious about what you should do on it
right now the only thing else I won't
hear that because I haven't seen this
much attention to the content and
engagement since very early 2007 and
eight right
just from a pure organic sampling if you
have a thousand people following their
stories
you have 900 in them who actually
consume it as when we play a game you
play a game where everything talks about
each having visitors this how we have
reach has nothing to do with actually
seven
I got a rap music I'm turning into a
fool to you on the rocks and now and
that's why that's why I'm so into you
are you get it you're only playing
practical in truth I I seem crazy as
[ __ ] I'm only practical but we're we're
not we're not afraid you'd if I'm
worried well that you have to that's it
God you look so much better now man when
do you take a picture this one was
really doesn't he know this whispers
look you're just [ __ ] rolling a
minute you like an idiot no no I'll go
with after my place on the book they
don't like it they don't want me to put
my face on it oh [ __ ] they're wrong
right as you know that you guys'll be
fine so the other thing you know that
that's more valuable than like like your
face in the book is the most out of a
part of the whole thing
yeah all right boom so that the other
thing is so see you guys later my god
you can India I'll give you the copy
India with the got this India with the
bump
Am I
stop chasing me yo not good I gotta get
here and check them out hello all right
what's going on
good to see you speak English yeah
snapchat stories yes and I tell you
right now for the first time
in a long time I'm obsessed I think it's
the biggest opportunity
you guys really change your business by
doing that so growth potential is
enormous it's fully being consumed my
twitter has never been more on fire than
Israel in seven years because you can't
talk here except one on one you can only
publicize it so there's a cross over
there this when people hit you up in and
you talk to them and you say this
Gayle's yakking the way they Twitter
reacted the way I put my brand yeah it's
a real moment if you know look I'm the
guy the [ __ ] food Jerome Jarre right
to ash the few days after intimate like
I know things like I know this last this
right now is that the right spot not
only six months ago wasn't it was still
too peer-to-peer it was still too young
it's like a spa and everybody by this
time next year is gonna do it yeah and
having that year's gonna matter that
put a lot of celebrities on it the Kim
Kardashian's about to go on
DJ colleges picture with her coming soon
and as Kim Kardashian like it's about to
get crazy honestly in a different way
dj khaled is the Ashton Kutcher moment
for Twitter
did you get that and then good it's good
to have you around you know be amazing
a startup that could literally
transcribe every word and make
everything searchable you just uploaded
the drives and like didn't I say yeah oh
I'm gonna love that no like it's coming
I'm going to drop to get two minutes do
you think Mexico so my first
my amazing business partners that
breathe who are the brightest minds in
the TV tech infrastructure world ever
they're setting up now artisan green
- mine
you're in so make your first ones like a
you spin them
I am finally back on snapchat after all
crazy no make sure to follow my boy
happy to be back I will be snapping away
here so yes
I
girl I've seen a little later
yeah thanks
so be rock is Maryland's the askgaryvee
show has historically but we've seen the
first one or two daily B's
yeah just to write yeah you're about to
be in the third we're doing it right now
awesome so Eric's working on a heart I
know I can see yes good it's been a
productive I mean I love any event that
brings a lot of my contacts into one
place where I've gotten 11 meetings that
would take me seven weeks and three
planes to accomplish today like I don't
know how people gonna go if you go read
the comments on Episode two right
there were people that basically said
things like I've been watching you for
three years healing you for three years
I didn't get how hard you actually work
yeah so I think one of the I think I'm
living a life that is an anomaly right
that I wish I documented all my cute to
this level because all the people that
think I was smart about Twitter they
don't even know how much and I think
this will do that infer that we're
capturing my conversation about snapchat
right now and 18 runs when snapchat is
literally the only other main platform
in the world I like as big as big yes
I'll have this narrative on how right I
was on its mainstream ability while so
many people in this hotel still think
that it's for kids for dick ready one
more time
is going to allow me to give away an
enormous amount of freedom but whereas I
could not do this yeah
charge every do you know many people of
tomorrow I announce I am no longer
putting up contest right I am creating
the Gary Vaynerchuk school mastermind of
market and it is $5,000 a month just get
what you've been getting do you know how
much money I would make tens of millions
of dollars
and that's what most people do because I
have this equal ambition yeah to six
because I think I have enough talent
what's going on with snare Cara it's
about to win attention with the
attention crowd power line for sex you
48 years old I'm going to
okay that's why I'm so good why is it
why what's it going for that
nothing else at the scale of 13 to 27
year olds that will educate the 22
six-year-olds to the value prop over top
okay Facebook yeah
those kids will move on to something
else that's right not those same kids
coming generations right right the next
generation
what do you think's on the horizon so
much good stuff here
and this is where everybody else loses
the people that are not doing it the
right way right I'm not playing you like
a violin because I'm putting in the work
right to make you say yes to the second
class
you're welcome
shorten the worst
it's always said let me Joe Gallo when
your annual trinkets yeah yeah oh yeah
yeah you gotta come you go you gotta get
you give me to me they're not like I
told ya yeah oh it's under you want
Richard can I text him to say bench okay
I need to show you already one okay no
I'm just gonna get to see your the block
okay I'm holding I was gonna say thank
you mentally I'm doing this on snapchat
it's [ __ ] with people's workin I'm
happy now but I do is maybe my favorite
okay I had my best friend's name a long
time right good for you
do you rock you love that oh yeah it's
not gonna make dailyvee
this family blog
playa yeah just just put that part there
number one piece of advice for all you
that are joining snapchat which is quite
a few sub-17
and what about this guy's batty then
ruby pulihora name anyway no more peace
advice google how to use snapchat
allocate 20 minutes read watch a couple
YouTube videos it will help so many of
you so much because it is a different
language problem yeah I've ability one
were you yes I don't remember what
that's really good it was a big
adventure you're gonna you're gonna end
up real team right that's gonna end up
being a real fun fact
cuz that's fingers gonna fire I hope so
yeah how you doing dear I'm good how are
you know okay happy to be in business
snapchat it's true I'm there lying
against [ __ ] [ __ ] on snapchat alright
going into this just wraps it up huh
yep you want to send you some video of
my other meeting slip you're the editing
in the room okay so out of the media
link party and instead of going to some
meetings I think I may go back to my
room and answer some a lot of young
entrepreneurs asking me what advice I'd
give them and my answer is patience
because you have a lot of time